cette affaire a été enterré six pieds
sous terre il ya 30 ans
je me disais qu'il y avait de grandes
chances qu'on ne le retrouve jamais ça
vous semble simple ça ne l'est pas
le gouvernement américain avec qui tu as
consacré une vie entière de service a
tourné le dos
en afghanistan pendant l'invasion
soviétique
[Musique]
il l'appelait la tête
qui paie partout
ce que je veux c'est comprendre comment
ça marche dans ton monde
comment tu écartes les obstacles
comment tu diriges tout ça le cheval tu
veux prendre la tow monnaie destination
qui te plaît rapport
tafer qui quel que soit l'endroit où tu
l'a caché sera bientôt partie prenante
de tout ça je me servirai d'elle pour
atteindre
papa la moindre idée de ce que j'ai fait
ni de l'homme que j'étais il ya un grand
méchant dans chaque histoire personne ne
se voit jamais comme le grand méchant de
l'histoire ne fait pas la bêtise de le
sous-estimer
il ne reculera devant rien pour assurer
sa propre survie
aucune limite que ce soit en termes de
dégâts physiques
moraux ou matériel
j'ai été créé
pour défendre ce qui a besoin de
défendre
[Musique]